(upbeat music)
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Alright, we are back,
and as a little kid,
our next guest was deemed a piano prodigy.
In the years that followed,
he merged his love of
classical music and hip hop
to develop his very own neoclassical vibe.
It's very cool. He's also toured worldwide
with some little known
artists like Rihanna,
Demi Lovato, Timberland,
and Justin Timberlake.
Now performing "Shadows x Light",
give it up for BLKBOK.
(audience cheering and applauding)
(piano music)
(piano music continues)
(audience clapping)
- Alright, one more time,
let's hear it for BLKBOK.
(audience cheering and applauding)
His new album, 9, is out now and
his single, "Shadows x
Light" drops February 21st.
Get it, check it out.
We'll be right back with
(Kelly drowned out by audience)